Hello, Conan O'Brien here.
I'm very excited because I'm about to do
what I've never done
before, an unboxing video.
I know these are huge.
I've never done one, but
I'm making an exception
because I'm a massive Neil Young fan
and his box set "Return to
Greendale" is coming out.
It's a live album and concert film
of the historic 2003 tour of Greendale,
which was Neil Young's 25th studio album.
He toured with Crazy Horse, very exciting.
This amazing box set was
released on November 6th.
Greendale of course,
very poignant story about
a fictional small town
in California, following a
family, an opera if you will,
and following their concerns
and their sort of dealing
with the environment,
the changes in the environment,
and really a passion project of Neil's
and excited to see what's in here.
I got my unboxing video blade right here.
And by the way, this is such an occasion
that Neil Young himself
has agreed to be present
sitting in my audience for this unboxing
of "Return to Greendale."
I think he's right there.
Look at him.
He looks thrilled.
It may appear to you at home that
that's just a cardboard
cutout of Neil Young.
I assure you that's the real Neil Young.
He just hasn't had his coffee yet.
Let's get started.
This is good.
Let's cut through the
red tape, as they say.
I'm cutting through this box right here.
This was sent to me and oh my
god, this is my favorite part.
The bubbles.
(bubbles crunch)
Sorry, here we go.
Oh, this is very nice.
Look at this presentation,
"Return to Greendale,"
Neil Young, Crazy Horse.
This is the actual box set itself.
This will have, it's
really the deluxe edition.
It's got the film.
Let's open this sucker up.
Find out what's going on.
I love the exterior.
I also love using this blade
because it shows me as a man
who knows how to use a knife.
And let's take a look, gorgeous, gorgeous.
This is exciting.
All right, checkin' it out right here.
Here we go.
Okay, beautiful.
Let me check this out.
I'm gonna use this.
Okay, here you have all
the songs, of course.
This is beautiful vinyl,
Neil Young, Crazy Horse,
and it has to be on vinyl.
Neil is passionate about that
and no better way to listen
to Neil and Crazy Horse.
And then I believe right
here, we have gorgeous.
This must be...
I'm guessing this is the film right here.
I think these are the films.
Can't be sure, but there's a great film,
Neil Young, Crazy Horse.
I wanna open this up
because I'm just curious
if there's more info in
here because this is a...
This tells a great story.
It's a concert video
and we're trying to...
Okay, gorgeous.
So this beautiful
representation photograph
of the concert itself, and
then album here with the words,
love that, beautiful.
And again, gorgeous vinyl,
beautiful vinyl, right?
I'm gonna be careful with that.
Absolutely, I love this.
I love the smell of vinyl.
Get a good whiff of that.
That's a good smelling vinyl
right there and really sweet.
This will be the film, the
documentary that goes with it,
where you get to see basically
this family in a small town
and you get to follow
them through their lives
and see what's happening to their land.
This is a great...
This is a great thing to
have and now I have it
unless cardboard Neil Young
takes it back and says,
"This was only for promotional purposes,"
which could happen, but
this is really cool.
I will treasure this if
I'm allowed to keep it.
And I will play this on my record player
'cause I do love vinyl, beautiful.
I'm even keeping the bubble wrap,
and let's maybe get Neil
to sign this for me.
I don't know if he can sign bubble wrap.
I hope he can.
Anyway, "Return to Greendale,"
Neil Young, Crazy Horse.
I have one, get one.
(sighs)